this episode is brought to you by curiositystream
a great subscription streaming service that
offers thousands of documentaries and non-fiction
titles from some of the world's best filmmakers
including exclusive originals trust me when
i say that this is content you're going to
want to see if you like content about virginia
woolf you might like to hear john green explain
her novel to the lighthouse or if you're looking
for something a bit more explosive how about 50
episodes of war in european history as explained
by john green evidently john green has some spare
time on his hands in between all of those books
and everything else that john green somehow does
curiosity stream is available on many
platforms web app roku android xbox one
smart tvs ios chromecast amazon fire amazon
apple tv it's available worldwide you can go
to curiositystream.com forward slash biographics
for unlimited access the world's top documentaries
and non-fiction titles and right now you guys
can use the promo code biographics to save 25
on the cost of an annual subscription which comes
out to just 14.99 a year which is crazy cheap so
click the link below or go to curiositystream.com
forward slash biographics and save 25
off right now making it just 14.99 for
the whole year and now today's video
today's protagonist once wrote a poignant thought
about the art of biography wondering whether the
lives of great men should only be recorded is
not anyone else who has lived a life and left
a record of that life worthy of biography
the failures as well as the successes the
humble as well as the illustrious ironically
today we will make our best effort to capture
at least some of the successes of her illustrious
life on paper she had a head start in life being
born into a family of wealthy intellectuals
but her existence was marred from the start
by mental illness and sexual abuse undeterred
the strength of her intellect plowed on and she
became one of the leading innovators of modernist
literature this is the life of virginia woolf
the baby who would become author virginia
woolf was born align virginia steven
on the 25th of january 1882 in hyde park
gate london her family background was rather
illustrious her grandfather said james steven had
authored the bill to abolish slavery in 1833. her
father leslie was an author and editor founder
of the dictionary of national biography in 1867
leslie had married minnie thackery daughter
of novelist william makepeace thackery the
two had a daughter laura in 1870 but five
years later many died of eclampsia after three
years of grieving lester remarried with julia
duckworth a model for pre-raphaelite painters
julia was also a widower and brought her
own three children into the household stella
gerald and george leslie and julia made it a point
to overcrowd even more their home by having four
further children together vanessa born in 1879
later to become a painter toby born in 1880 was
a promising intellectual but he died aged just
26. virginia and adrian in 1883 who would become
a psychoanalyst the four steven siblings were
very close and highly gifted from an early age
virginia displayed a talent for writing stories
since the age of five penning long serials about
evil spirits lurking in rubbish heaps as much
as virginia loved her crowded house in london
her favorite place was thailand house the
family summer getaway incentive's cornwall
from its windows she admired the views of
godrevy lighthouse towering above the sea
or enjoyed the sounds of children playing in
the terraced gardens in the evenings she would
compose short stories in the style of nathaniel
hawthorne all those memories of sentai stayed
with virginia well into adulthood to the point
that she later wrote how her entire life was
built on that permeated by that how much so i
could never explain virginia's love for writing
and reading drew very close to her father the
two would spend hours together sharing books or
making up stories virginia and leslie took long
walks together during which she taught her to dig
into the more prosaic aspects of everyday life and
extract fountains of poetic interest nonetheless
leslie had an ambivalent attitude towards the role
of women as intellectuals while he encouraged his
daughters to read write and learn he did not
believe women could lead productive literary
or artistic careers as virginia grew older
she resented this patriarchal attitude but
she had other more problematic male figures
in her life gerald duckworth one of her
much older half-brothers had once touched her
inappropriately while on holiday at some dives
he was 18 at the time virginia was only six
this incident left her prone to sexual fear and
instilled in her a resistance to aggressive
masculine authority this event surely clouded the
idyllicness of her childhood but the worst was to
come when virginia entered her teens in may 1895
her mother julia died of heart failure julia's
daughter stella duckworth took on the mantle
of surrogate mother but two years later she too
died due to complications of pregnancy with julia
and stella gone there was no one else to keep
tabs on virginia's other half-brother george
according to virginia's own memoirs george would
visit her at night forcing himself on her and
calling her beloved but by day he would ridicule
her looks and called her the poor goat it was too
much for a 15 year old girl to take in september
1897 virginia first recorded in her journal
a wish to die this diary is lengthening indeed
but death would be shorter and less painful
virginia soldiered on but life kept treating
her like a punching bag delivering jabs
and hooks of misery first leslie died in march
1904. understandably the 22 year old virginia
suffered a mental collapse which led to her
attempting suicide by jumping out of a window
she recovered thanks to violet dickinson a
friend of the late stella varla was older
wise and kind just the type of motherly figure
the young virginia needed val nursed her back to
health physically and mentally along the way the
two developed a friendship which eventually became
romantic during the same eventful year virginia
and her sister vanessa moved to gordon's square
in the bloomsbury area of london this was the
epicenter of bohemian life in london an area
rife with non-conformist intellectuals many
of whom gravitated around the stephen siblings
their friends included activist and author
leonard wolff biographer lytton strachey
artist roger fry economist john maynard keynes
and art critic clive bell who would later marry
vanessa by moving into that milieu virginia and
vanessa were rejecting the habits and values
expected from two young ladies in edwardian
england they replaced polite small talk with
discussions about politics and literature or
shopping trips with visits to art galleries
and during the summer of 1905 virginia ditched
london's high society events for long walks across
cornwall's countryside during that period she
kept a diary which became the origin of her later
narrative experiments in her journal virginia
described how she abandoned the well-trodden roads
to venture into barely visible paths ignoring
the artificial barriers imposed by man on nature
these ramblings were an early metaphor for her
later works in which the narrative ignored the
artificial signposts imposed by traditional plot
lines a character's birth a marriage someone's
death virginia would instead explore apparently
insignificant moments in time which nonetheless
can shape someone's life virginia's own
life however was to be shaped by the tritest
of plot points the death of another character in
1906 older brother toby succumbed to typhoid while
traveling in greece this event appeared
to ignite a steady decline in virginia's
mental health although initially she did her
best to remain mentally active and productive
while working as a teacher in a night school for
workers in south london she composed her first
short story phyllis and rosamund the plot was
inspired by virginia and vanessa's own experiences
in london's upper middle class milo or better it
explored the question what would happen to two
intelligent and ambitious sisters should they not
have escaped from that environment the answer was
they would have been trapped in a lifeless limbo
like hazy figures in the background of a party two
non-entities little more than decorative props
waiting for someone to marry them and yet virginia
felt that even this state of non-existence so
common so typical of the era was worth recording
unlike a protagonists virginia pretty much stood
out from the background getting involved in
the big political issues of the time such as
the campaign for women's rights and suffrage
but eventually her mind deteriorated and in
july of 1910 virginia was committed to burley
sanatorium in twickenham she absolutely loaded the
experience writing to vanessa that she saw jumping
out of a window is there any way out this extreme
means of escape was not necessary however and
virginia was dismissed after less than two months
upon a release virginia moved into a new house in
brunswick square bloomsbury sharing lodgings with
her brother adrian and other friends leonard wolff
was one of them and he was interested in becoming
more than just a friend the two got engaged and
eventually married on august 10 1912. leonard
was a positive presence in virginia's life he
helped her cope with the belts of mental illness
and coached her into writing her first novel
the voyage out but the relationship was not
entirely a bed of roses leonard could not or would
not consider virginia's sexual fears and history
of abuse he even considered her to be a sexual
failure from her side virginia had no qualms in
offending leonard's background introducing him
as a penniless jew the adjustment to married
life and tensions that came with it may have
pushed wolfe into a period of depression in 1913.
her doctor sent her back to burley for another
summer in the abyss when virginia walked out she
was suicidal on september 9th she consulted with
two distinguished psychiatrists dr morris
wright and the aptly named sir henry head
all they could advise was a third admission to
burley something that virginia could not swallow
what she did swallow instead was a massive dose of
bobituards she barely survived thanks to leonard
and dr head who arrived at the right time and
pumped her stomach whilst recovering she threw
herself into finalizing the voyage out published
in march of 1915. the novel lays out some of the
main themes that wolff would explore in later work
such as the stifling condition of married women in
early 20th century britain the voyage out was well
received by critics but it was not a best-seller
moreover the stress associated with its
publication led virginia to suffer another
mental breakdown a violent episode of incoherent
screaming followed by a comatose state this
was followed by another admission at burley the
medical staff tried to persuade leonard and her
family that virginia's sanity had gone worn out by
neuroasthenia or nervous exhaustion contemporary
psychiatrists tend to agree that she was beset
by bipolar disorder instead driven by both nature
and by nurture mental illness ran in her family
granddad james suffered from cyclothymia which
causes intense mood swings he had been
institutionalized after running naked
through cambridge and he died in an asylum
her dad leslie was also cyclothymic while
her mom julia suffered from depression her
siblings and half-siblings were not immune
either laura leslie's daughter from his previous
marriage suffered from an undefined psychosis
vanessa and adrian had cyclothymia 2 and the
unfortunate phobia experienced hypermanic episodes
virginia's already fragile mental state was
further compromised by the traumatic experience
suffered since childhood the series of deaths in
the family and the vile sexual abuse perpetrated
by the darkworth boys and yet it would be
reductive to identify virginia woolf with
a mental health condition her vitality resilience
and sheer willpower would not allow her to succumb
to institutionalization she would not accept to
lead a life defined by malay a life adrift driven
by the storms of mania or the dead calm
of depression against all medical opinion
by november 1915 virginia had recovered and was
ready to leave burley after 20 years of half-life
she was ready to throw open the curtains and
take on the most productive period of her life
after virginia's recovery leonard was still
worried that the effect of writing would
cause her to have another breakdown and looked
for a distraction for her as virginia had an
interest in printing and binding books by
hand he ordered a hand printing machine
this activity started as a hobby but soon it
became a business hogarth press the wolves
initially used hogarth press to publish their
own works this was a relief for virginia who
dreaded submitting a manuscript to the prong eyes
of editors and publishers soon they expanded their
catalogue to include small and experimental works
likely to be rejected by commercial publishers
these included writings by their friends iam
foster and john mayne at keynes but also by
sigmund freud and t.s eliot in 1919 virginia
released her short story q gardens via hogarth
press the story contrasts the aimless meandering
of eight characters against the purposeful march
of a snail and attracted the attention of the
times literary supplement the favorable review
led to hundreds of orders and commercial success
so much so that leonard and virginia had to forego
the hand printing press and hire a commercial
printer while hogarth press was taking off
virginia was completing her second novel night and
day published in october of 1919. wolff explores
again the theme of women who struggle to achieve
their full potential locked in a society who
accepts them only as wives and daughters the main
character catherine actively opposes her emilio of
upper class intellectuals first by embracing
mathematics instead of poetry and then by
rejecting the courtship of a poet as she pursues
the love of an upstart solicitor night and day was
the first in a series of writings in which wolf
shaped the defining characteristics of the modern
novel she introduced the principle that writers
did not need sensational events to propel a story
or develop a character an ordinary mind on an
ordinary day was worthy of being narrated in a
novel she aimed to capture the moments of being
these ordinary minds climatic inward events or
epiphanies that may strike her characters while
they conduct the most mundane activities morph
adopted these principles in a follow-up novels
jacob's room of 1922 and mrs dalloway published
in 1925. the latter novel takes place over a
single day in june a concept inspired by jane's
joyce ulysses mrs clarissa delaway roams london
looking to buy flowers for a party that she's
throwing she's renowned amongst london's high
society as bright and a lively hostess although
she is not entirely satisfied with her own life
clarisse's urban travels are mirrored by her
internal meanderings as she questions the
meaning of her own existence and reminisces
about her first love peter and about her lone
homosexual experience wolff then introduces the
second main character septimus warren smith a
world war one veteran afflicted by shell shock
smith is plagued by hallucination by an inability
to feel emotions and worst of all by poor medical
treatment the two never meet but during the party
clarissa overhears a guest telling how septimus
committed suicide earlier that day by jumping out
of a window despite this tragic revelation the
novel ends on an optimistic note by reflecting on
septimus's suicide clarissa finds a new interest
in the beauty of life and reconnects with former
love peter many contemporary critics and readers
consider mrs dalloway as wolff's best novel
but it's a close tie with a follow-up title
to the lighthouse published in may 1927. the
book is divided into three sections the window
time passes and the lighthouse the first section
the window takes place over a single day the
ramses are at their holiday home on the isle of
skye stand in for the stevens's own retreat in
cornwall one of the children james is planning a
boat trip to a lighthouse but his father talks him
out of it claiming bad weather the second and
shorter section time passes covers 10 years of
events including world war one during this period
the ramsey house a symbol for civilization rots
away abandoned the house was left the house was
deserted it was left like a shell on a sand hill
to fill with dry salt grains now that life had
left it in this section wolff hastily introduces
the death of important characters as quick edits
in between square brackets our favorite example
is a shell exploded 20 or 30 young men were blown
up in france among them andrew ramsay whose death
mercifully was instantaneous in the final section
the lighthouse james finally completes his trip to
the lighthouse 10 years after originally
planned as with many of wolff's novels
it's difficult to pinpoint a single key theme
the more evident ones are the nature of time and
how patterns of delay repetition and inaction
can affect one's life despite its complexity
the novel was well received by critics and readers
much to the surprise of the author on june 6 1927
she noted in a diary they don't laugh at me any
longer possibly i shall be a celebrated writer
the celebrated writer defied all expectations with
the next work orlando a biography of 1928. almost
fantasy in tone the novel features the titular
character who switches gender at a whim and lives
through centuries of british history the novel
defies the traditional linear concept of time as
the protagonist accumulates memories each of them
becoming a wormhole transporting her or him back
to a different period but orlando can also be read
as a fictional biography of a real life character
poet novelist and horticulturalist vita sackville
west vita and virginia had first met in 1923
struck up a friendship and took holidays together
in france and italy virginia idolized vita and
their friendship developed into a short romance
which became physical only on two occasions the
unstoppable wolf hit the bookshelves again the
following year with the essay a room of one zone
one of her most celebrated feminist writings in
this work virginia addresses the pressures which
deny the intellectual and professional development
of women the confinement to the domestic sphere
conformity to the patriarch but most of all the
inability for women to have their own income
and privacy hence the title a woman must have
money and a room of her own if she has to ride
the essay also looks at how history is written
as a succession of wars waged by powerful kings
and generals wolff invites readers to consider
a counter-historiography instead one focused on
those women excluded from historical records
generations of mothers and daughters who
maintained domestic order and social peace which
were regularly destroyed by militaristic thugs
the next effort was 1931's the waves virginia's
most experimental work the narrative is structured
as six soliloquies voiced by three men and three
women over a single day they are all coping with
the death of a dear friend the characters do
not show any external expression of grief but
the author reveals their personalities
through their internal stream of consciousness
in 1932 the writer launched into another ambitious
project which occupied her for the next five years
this was the years a family chronicle which became
wolf's best-selling work during a lifetime here
will follows the extended pargdar family heavily
influenced by our own each section starts with
a sweeping narration describing the sky
over britain or london in particular before
zooming in to the consciousness of a particular
character their seemingly random activities
dialogues and thoughts take the reader through
50 years of british history and institutions
analyzing how they've shaped the consciousness of
individuals the initial draft included a running
social commentary on the condition of women which
virginia edited out and then published in 1938 as
three guineas the second feminist essay identifies
the dominant issues for women of the 20th century
lack of access to education and professional
advancement if women were so excluded from
the public sphere how could they prevent
the world from slipping into another war
according to wolfe exclusion of women led to
an unbridled patriarchal society which in turn
had a direct link to the rise of fascism in europe
and thus to the risk of international conflict
that conflict world war ii of course broke out
eventually in september of 1939. virginia had
started working on what would be a final novel
between the acts which she continued writing
under the blitz in september of 1940 the wolf's
home in bloomsbury was bombed by the loftwater
and virginia and leonard moved into their country
home monk's house in rodmell sussex rodmill lies
a little less than five kilometers from new haven
unbeknownst to them this was the intended landing
port for operation sea lion the planned nazi
invasion of britain and little did they know that
heinrich himmler head of the ss had included their
names in a list of intellectuals to be immediately
arrested while he had no knowledge of these plans
leonard feared a german landing and was aware of
the dangers for a jew and his wife he devised
contingency plans for him and virginia to commit
suicide together an idea the writer didn't like
one bit as she was still busy with a novel but
the hard work on between the acts and the tension
created by the war were taking a heavy toll on her
virginia could feel that her mind was beginning
to falter she feared that her mental illness would
resurface violently on the 27th of march virginia
wrote to a publisher confiding that she was not
satisfied with her current draft and she aimed
to revise it later in the year did she really
plan to continue working on her latest novel we
only know that the following day she did pick
up pen and paper but to leave a note for leonard
dearest i feel certain i'm going mad again i feel
we can't go through another of those terrible
times and i shan't recover this time around 11
45 am virginia will filled her pockets with stones
walked into the fast current of the rivers and let
herself drown her body was recovered only on the
18th of april leonard buried her ashes in their
garden under one of the two elms with interlaced
branches they had called them leonard and virginia
so i really hope you enjoyed today's video sort
of tangential events going on in this series
world war one and world war ii and i have a new
channel called war of graphics which covers some
of the biggest battles and wars from history so if
you'd like to learn more about the background of
today's video please do go check out that channel
it's linked below and thank you for watching
you